how did you get your first script in the
hands of john carpenter well it was the
first thing i i wrote i'd been working
as a producer on indie films and and
music videos and commercials and was
like i'm gonna take the leap into
screenwriting so i saved enough money
for one year to just work on
screenwriting
and um had this idea to do like a very
pulp fiction type horror film you know
kind of non-linear and i had a friend
who was a screenwriter sean keller who
became my writing partner and we'd never
worked together
we just decided to write it and just
after three months just working on the
script with like
you know no expectations we ended up
getting a manager from it because it was
so unusual and odd and different than
what was out there and then from there
you know i get a call a few weeks later
said john carpenter read it loves it so
i grew up watching his movies and by the
way he's the greatest guy on the face
the earth he's the coolest dude you
could ever meet so he read the script
liked it and was very interested in
directing it and his process was to sit
there with the script
and read it aloud to us
page by page and everything that he
didn't like or thought wasn't good he'd
just go come on
you could do better than that which was
which was a learning experience in
itself
and it showed it taught me a lot about
what directors are looking for
and what they want and he was a great
teacher and the film never got made but
it was a really good experience and then
from that
we actually did an uncredited rewrite on
his last film uh the award so it worked
out great because we got paid to to
rewrite the film so we've worked with
carpenter twice and he's a really good
dude
and so this was the second script that
you and your writing partner had that
was actually the first one oh okay sorry
but but how did you
how did this manager and how did all
this even get in the hands of john
carpenter well i had spent time like the
first 10 years of work in the film
industry i worked for production
companies and produced some indie films
and things so i kind of knew how the
business worked a little bit i had an
unfair advantage to most people just
stepping in but i spent 10 years working
in the world and making some connections
and also understanding how
you know scripts work so i really had
worked on a few things where it's like i
could probably write as well as that you
know or even
you know saw what other people were
making and some other screenplays i was
like i think i could do that so
that's kind of where it came out of and
just you know
we also knew that we had to write
something that was really unusual out of
the box we didn't write a script to be
made we wrote a script to get noticed
and that's where i think really it
worked it was like okay this gets made
that's great but people will not forget
the script and it did what it was
supposed to do because it got us you
know it got us a manager and then later
got us an agent from another script and
just kept the ball rolling and people
still ask me about that script and we've
optioned it
i don't know maybe six or seven times
the last 15 years still hasn't been made
but
it's it's done well
and
when you sat down with uh john carpenter
where was this like an office building
yeah he has like i'm not going to say
where's office but he has
yeah he has an old craftsman i think
maybe he lived there like
20 30 years ago that he still owns it's
been converted into office so it's cool
you go in there and all his posters are
up all his scripts are there you know he
just sits in the back office and
and just you know most of time when we
would talk about the script we'd also
talk about basketball and music and all
these other things and
he gave me a lot of advice about the
film business you know he would say you
know people are going to rip you off
they're going to do this they're going
to do that don't start writing until you
get paid
you know do this and that and one of the
best stories i have about him
is when we were doing a uh rewrite on
the ward for him there was a big
conference call with all these producers
and everybody kept telling us what to do
and he stopped everyone and he just said
hey let let them go do what they do
and it was the coolest thing because we
knew all we had to do was just talk to
carpenter you know it's like
deal with everybody else and pretty much
the script the rewrite we did was the
movie that that you saw so
yeah
and when he started going through the
script and saying you can do better than
that
did he did he show you what better was
within the script no he no he's he let
you he kind of treated you as a
professional it's like this can be
better which means you need to go figure
out how to make it better you know and
just some lines he'd be like you know a
hero would never say that the lead of
the movie wouldn't say that
you know so it was a good good you know
education and understanding that like
they're not gonna do the work for me and
things i didn't do correctly in a script
it's like you know and and that's not
necessarily their job it's like this
isn't working so you need to give me
option a b and c
so that was a really good lesson you
know from somebody who knows
films backwards and forwards
and so when you and sean left there
with your whether you put paper clips or
post-it notes or
whatever how are you racking your brain
to go why didn't he like this what you
know like no it was just like i can't
believe we're hanging out john carpenter
more more than anything but but he was
so he's he's like like he's probably one
of the best people i've ever met not
just in the film business but just a
great great person and super cool and
just
you know gives great advice and it was
just he didn't do it because
he was you know from a place of like
come on it was more like you can do
better and he would say you can do
better just you know was really pushing
and and really
dug the script and you know to have
somebody who you watch these movies
growing up say that is like you better
listen
you know so it was part it was it's part
of educating yourself i still i've been
doing this 15 years professionally as a
screenwriter i'm trying to educate
myself all the time to get better every
day
so
good lesson
and jim were you paid for the script no
that one was just work to try to get it
to the finish line that happens
sometimes sometimes things are options
sometimes they're not if you're you have
a good attachment like a director like
him
you know you sometimes work on trying to
get to the next level to go out to get
the financing
so not every job you know every every
project you work on is
you know you're not always getting paid
sometimes you have to you have to make
that decision do you want to do the work
to try to get to the next level or do
you want to try to get paid you know
sometimes there's no one's going to pay
you so it's like there's it's either the
market doesn't want it right now or will
want it with attachments or you know
it's a tricky thing most people in the
film business you won't make money
unless multiple people want to buy the
project if just one person wants to make
it they're like sure we'll give you an
option we'll do this um we may have
optioned that script i don't really
remember but
it wasn't you know it was never
purchased so
and a lot of times you just get an
option you don't get paid for a script
you read these stories of people you
know selling a script here or there that
happens but if you're more in the indie
world 10 million and under you option a
script maybe they'll give you five grand
maybe they'll give you 10 grand maybe
they'll give you a hundred dollars and
when the movie gets made the first day
of shootings when they actually pay for
the script
so if you want to be a team player and
get the movie mate you have to work a
lot for free
and so going there you and sean both
knew
we're not going to be paid but we see
the opportunity exactly down the line
exactly it was like having a master
class it's like you know it's yeah where
the guy's sitting there you can ask me
if you want so that's great
what's the story behind your first
screenplay sale so first screenplay sale
was the script we wrote after
the john carpenter project which is
called elli gothic this was called
damned and this script was got out and
it was picked up by a pretty big
producer
and
they arranged the financing for the film
and they actually paid for the script
and
what happened was a few days before
shooting it was fully cast
um i think they were shooting on like a
monday and this was friday the cast was
getting on plane flights to fly out to
missouri
and they get these frantic calls like
don't get on the plane because the money
fell out three days before principal
photography and that happens sometimes
in films until you're actually
i even have the theory that on an indie
film until you're actually finished
shooting
you don't that's when you don't really
have to worry about the money so much
you have to worry about post but i've
worked on films where sometimes they
don't have all the money they say they
they do so
it's a problem that happens but
you know it was it was sad we got paid
at least
you know we got the rights to script
back they were great to give us that
back because the movie didn't get made
and we optioned it several more times
but it was you know it was very
disappointing because that was the first
thing i thought was going to get made
and it didn't it got very close and it
just fell apart but you know you live
and you learn and then you move on to
the next project keep going so that
didn't deter you no not at all
no it's like it was it actually made me
think even more okay we got to work even
harder on the next project and and get
something made cause it came so close
and finally we're making some money as
screenwriters and and we were like let's
do it it's not like you know no actually
it actually emboldened me to even go
harder and things
and so in a case like that
who calls the the actors the location is
that's the producer that's yeah making
all these horrible calls that's probably
got to be very difficult
yeah and so
there was no chance of maybe in a month
it was basically this is done they they
talked about it but usually in these
kind of projects if that happens it's
it's kind of hard to regroup you spend
so many months putting the whole team
together doing everything getting the
actors in line you know getting their
schedules making deals and then for it
all to go sideways and not know when
you're going to pick it back up
it's very difficult it does happen don't
get me wrong but it's it becomes like
okay
you know there's a little bit of a
jinx on a project at that point so you
just kind of have to move on and and
just try to make the next one
and sorry this was your first screenplay
that you wrote or you second oh second
okay with sean yeah okay
and with the first one um
did you
expect anything from that that was the
john carpenter one you know the
expectations were just to get noticed
really
because it was it was really kind of
crazy and and that's another thing i
talk to people a lot about it's like you
know what are your expectations with the
script is it you know if you write
something to sell it or to get it made
or to get noticed
and a lot of i think young screenwriters
don't try to write something to get
noticed
you know because if you want to do this
for a living it's something that you've
got to like you're not just going to
write one script you're going to be
writing every day all the time and have
tons of scripts
do you think
the chain of events would have happened
today
because things have changed so rapidly
in so many ways do you think that same
story could be duplicated again
either one whether you get a script that
you know you won't be paid for but into
the hands of some master class person
basically a master definitely happens
all the time
a lot of people who become big writers
um they they write a script that turns
into a sample
and even i've had that several times my
career where there's like a sample of
like a horror film that everybody was
into and then a thriller that everybody
was into and then i recently wrote a
really big action film that that's
getting a lot of traction right now but
it's also just in the last few weeks
got me up for some big writing gigs
because you know if you're trying to get
a job for a 80 million dollar action
film you can't show them a one million
dollar horror film you have to have that
sample that gets people's attention and
you know professional high level
producers read they know by your sample
if you can do the other job
so you know you have to have samples
that fit that that kind of what you the
type of work you're looking for
so it was a great sample so
your two screenplays that you had one
that was looked at and and scrutinized
by john carpenter the other one that was
ready for production and it fell through
a few days beforehand what did both
those situations teach you about writing
they just taught you i mean they taught
me to be
just part of the process because
you know you start working with
directors and producers and actors and
even though neither neither of those
projects got made you realize that like
you're not
an individual in this process you have
to you have to be a team player you have
to work with all these different people
that have their their input and maybe
producer a has some good ideas and
producer b has horrible ideas but
producer b might be giving you the money
for the film so it's like how do you
navigate those waters so that was that
was what i took out of those more than
anything it's like
it's not
i i don't get to do what i want
but i've got to try to like you know
navigate to a sense to where i can make
it what i want or win some of the
battles but i'm not going to win them
all
and you just don't have a choice when
someone pays you for something they own
it
you know it's like it's like if you sold
your house and then you're like well i
don't want them to tear out the hardwood
floors they're going to do it anyway so
you know a lot of it is is doing that as
being figuring out how to like navigate
those waters of like to keep the
integrity of your script and still get
the movie made because that's a very
you know delicate balance between the
two
you had been in the film industry before
you said were you working as a script
reader or around script readers no i
actually had worked at uh streamline
pictures which was the company that
brought all the anime over to america in
the 90s i worked for carl masik and how
i got that job was i got out of college
i played in a band
and the drummer had gotten a job there
marketing and i was like i need a job so
he goes i'll get you one so he got me a
job there and it was a really
interesting
environment because streamline was like
did so many things they produced films
they they imported films
they created content they they were like
really ahead of the game in a lot of
ways and carl masik was like probably
the first mentor i ever had he passed
away a few years ago but he was a great
guy and just kind of let us do our own
thing he'd be like
call universal and see if we can set up
this film well how just figure it out
you know so you'd just be left your own
devices so
from that i working at that company i
learned a lot about films and and the
industry and the business part which i
think is still an advantage i have over
a lot of other people in the film
industry that i understand how the
the money works and where it flows back
and forth and and what's the bottom line
of making a film
so from there
i worked on some indie films i produced
some indie films after that and you know
some commercials some music videos and
you know just learned about production
as much as i could and didn't even on
the indie films i worked on i didn't
just sit in a chair i i sat there with a
line producer and learned how to you
know line by line how to budget a film
how to do all that stuff because it was
just like if i'm going to do this for a
living i need to know as much as i can
about everything every department
so that's pretty much what i took away
from that
is that something that you think is to
your advantage i mean have you always
been that way where you cut you you
don't you you just need to be told where
point b is or a is and you'll find a way
how to get yeah i i'm a little bit both
right brain and left brain so i can i'm
one of those few people that can like do
a budget but i can also write a script
you know there's not a lot of people
like that so i don't know why i can do
that but
it's it's you know you you when you
understand
the business points of like why people
are investing two three million dollars
in a film and what they want out of it
it becomes a little bit easier to shape
the creative side too
how'd that help
it did
what would you say to people that say
well i only do this though i mean i mean
some people think that you know what it
was
jack of all trades master of none and
they don't they don't want to get in in
that situation but then there's a real
um power in knowing how many different
things work
yeah and and and here's the thing this
is what i always try to
the more you know about the film
business
the better it's going to help you you
don't have to be an expert but you have
to kind of understand how things work
because this is the one thing i always i
always try to explain to people that are
want to get into screenwriting
they'll be like hey i wrote the script
it's my first script i want to get it
out to producers i want to send it to
people i want to get it made and they
want someone who they don't know who's
who they've never made money for to give
them two million dollars now if you just
take that aside
and you think
that you want to start a restaurant but
you've never worked one day in a
restaurant you've never even been in the
kitchen of a restaurant and you write a
business plan for a restaurant and you
go to somebody who invests in
restaurants and say can i have two
million dollars for this restaurant
they're gonna think you're crazy but for
some reason screenwriters think oh i
wrote the script someone should give me
two million dollars it's
yet it's their first script it's their
first business plan they haven't spent
any time in the industry
and think somebody's gonna write a check
for two million dollars because it's
that good
i mean maybe there are a couple scripts
they're that good that people just can
throw millions of dollars at you but
there's like that's like a handful
on the planet so
people don't understand it's like that's
one of the things that like i try to
instill in people is like if you want to
be a screen screenwriter and do it
professionally you maybe your sixth or
seventh will be good enough to show to a
producer your first script about your
uncle isn't going anywhere
you know and there's millions of those
and
that's the problem is like it's not hard
to become a professional screenwriter
but you have to do the work and you have
to understand the business that's what
people don't do a lot of times
and is there a hazing with all the
knocks that you're going to get and all
the stuff that's going to be the plug's
going to be pulled and then
yeah you have to have very very thick
skin and something that took me a long
time to understand too is you have to
interpret notes because sometimes
producers don't like something but they
can't tell you what they don't like so
they say no a and it kind of doesn't
make sense you have to figure it out you
have no guideline because there's i've
worked with both kinds of producers
really fantastic a-list producers and
other ones that are good at like putting
a film together but can't articulate the
creative side so you have to figure out
what they don't like
and that's your job
and you know that sometimes it's just
alchemy you're like you've got to get
inside their head and understand why
they don't like the first act
and when we hear about these
wunderkind or whatever that's like their
first thing and then it's picked up and
it's probably more so maybe in the past
i don't know
how much does that spoil us as writers
or creatives because we think oh i'm
going to be the next one yeah it does i
mean
it does because those stories get told
over and over but they're so few and far
between i know a lot of filmmakers i
know a lot of directors i know a lot of
writers
and there's very few films that
completely change your life
it's more like a stepping stone from
this to this like maybe you'll do this
movie and then you'll get that one
you'll direct a bigger move you went
from directing a million dollar movie to
5 million to 30. but there are those
things where people get hit by lightning
you know but
i always try to say that 50 of
of getting a project put together is
super hard work being talented
staying focused and the other 50 is
timing and luck because the market can
change
you know within minutes
because we had a script that was this
thriller
that people liked we put it on the
market and we had some people really
interested in it and then taking came
out like two weeks later and then
suddenly
my agent got like 20 calls like the next
morning hey you know that and it wasn't
really even like taken but it just was
like a revenge thriller and it's like so
suddenly the script that everybody's
kind of into becomes everybody's into
because something was a hit so you can't
control that you can't control the
market you have to just do the best work
and hope that you know it goes somewhere
sure it found footage you know yeah
yeah yeah things change so something you
wrote even now like i've had people like
talk to me about like older scripts like
hey what about that and i'm like i don't
even want to send it to you because i
feel like a i'm a better writer and b
things have changed it's just that was
written 12 years ago it's not the same
kind of way
movies are made because things do evolve
i think i've heard you say it's not
about selling a screenplay it's about
getting the movie made
yes
yes how how are those two things
different well i mean
you you could sell screenplay if you
want to make some money and that's great
but you know the in my mindset it's like
if i love this script and i want to get
made i not only want to get paid but i
want to get it made because
in the long term you know sure you make
some money but
you know the reason a lot of us are
doing this is to create things so you
know if it's a document that's just
sitting there you know in a drawer
not many people are going to see it but
if it's on netflix or something you can
get out of the world so yeah i try to
like be very focused on like how do i
get a movie made
but i also have a personality where once
i start getting into some i i won't let
it go until
you know and just push and push and push
the movie rage which we did with nick
cage
that movie
took five years to get made you know and
it was like a five-year like hall of
constantly working and pushing it up the
hill at one time antoine fuqua actually
often optioned the script he was going
to direct it and that would have been
fantastic
and then we had this other director and
other people were involved one time
ethan hawk was going to be the movie it
just kept
falling apart getting put together
but
you know we had to have that tenacity of
like all these setbacks the script's too
good not to get made
you know and and a lot of people said
it's a great script it's too bad it
didn't get made you know so i'm like
okay well it's gonna get made and it
took us five years to get it made and it
finally got made but it's it's just a
different kind of mindset of like
you know if you want to be in the film
business obviously the end
game is to get movies made
you know the flip side of that which is
kind of like
strange is that sometimes you can get
hired to write a tv pilot that never
gets made and you make a lot more money
than a film that does get made
you know so
you have to kind of temper that like
don't get me wrong i'm i'm a capitalist
and i love getting paid but i also want
to get a movie made and completed and
finished so
were you always like this where you
wanted to see something through to the
end yeah i'm very good so you know i'm
also i'm working on not being miserable
until it's finished you know i have a
bad habit of like not enjoying the
process which i've got much better at
the last few years but it's kind of a
mindset like you have to just be focused
on like
the the finish line and not let go you
know until it's done because movie a
million things can go wrong even even
after you shoot it everything can go
wrong in post you know you could run out
of money things could go you know
sideways the the editor
does a bad job you know we had a
director on a film
we had a fire in post and i had to do
the sound mix and the other producer had
to do the color timing so and we had to
reshoot the beginning so
it's a it's a process but we got the
movie finished
so let's take that screenwriter though
that is that first screenplay that's
he's writing about his uncle his uncle
has a pawn shop and he just he's the
coolest guy and everybody needs to see
this film at what point do you tell that
person
and and they have this tenacity i don't
think it's gonna work
yeah um that's a good question um but
they have to also kind of like have some
self-reflection of like what is this
script doing for producers like at the
end of the day every movie is made for
one reason it's not a creative endeavor
it's to make money i mean secondarily
it's creative endeavor but you know you
have to make money unless you find some
rich uncle who's a billionaire just
wants to throw tax shelters at you you
know that's a whole different story but
you know if it's not working
that script what's wrong with that
script is there not a market for it does
it do producers not you know you know
have you know do they not get sparked to
it
what is the thing that's going to get
you to the
to the next level you know if that
script's not working write another
script you know write something maybe
more commercial write something more you
know personal what what is not
connecting with people on that script
because the thing is what i hear from
agents and managers all the time is like
99 of scripts i get are horrible you
know people pitching them things are
horrible ideas
and it's like if you write some if you
write well and you have a great script
it will get noticed it might not get
made you might not get money but you'll
get some kind of notice on it but
what is the level of that good script is
it did you spend three months on it did
you spend two years and keep rewriting
the same script over and over sometimes
things don't work
i i mean i don't know on my computer the
other day i found
probably 40 scripts that were half
written or the first act
and i'm like okay it's not working it
didn't come out the way i thought it was
and i don't see how it's gonna be great
to sell i actually have two full scripts
right now i've written
that like i thought were gonna be great
i'm like i don't know they're not what i
want to put out right now
so i just put them away maybe i'll come
back them later maybe i'll never even
look at them again
but if you want to work as a
professional writer and work all the
time
that's what you've got to do
is just keep
you know grow one script isn't going to
make a career you know
so follow-through is great tenacity
but at some point having
some type of an awareness that when
you're getting notes or you're just
getting just complete rejection that
there's a sign there yes yes okay and
you know sometimes it's good like if
you're working on something that's not
working people are not you know
you know having any kind of reaction to
it try something else
you know put it away write another kind
of script you know see what people feel
i mean the problem is too a lot of
people give scripts
to their friends and ask their opinion
they just go that's great you know or or
even people who don't know
a script from you know don't work in the
film business you which that's kind of
like a problem too it's like you know i
know a lot of people subscribe to these
like you know they pay for uh
coverage or they pay for script notes
and you know who's giving you those
script notes somebody who's never worked
on a movie you know maybe they know a
little bit more about you so you have to
be very careful those things can be very
educational and can help but you i don't
i don't ever like when people spend a
ton of money on those things you know
because i feel like they're getting
ripped off at some point because if you
want to learn how to make a movie the
templates there
there's hundreds of thousands of movies
on netflix you can watch that have been
made you just have to find movies like
what you want to do you know if you want
to write a personal story you know or a
story about
you know you and your friends and some
girl dumped you watch swingers the
template's there it doesn't have to be
the same story but you can follow the
beats and you can see how you know it
flows and where you you know the second
act turn happens and where the
resolution comes in and what's the arc
it's it's all been
done for you
making it sound really easy aren't i
well
some people are self-aware and some
people aren't so yeah have you ever paid
for script coverage have you ever no
you've never no i've never read a book
about how to write screenplay or
anything but
i found that i work
a lot of intuition but i also but what i
do though sometimes and even now that
i've been doing this i'm in the writers
guild i've done it for a long time make
a living at this
even recently i pulled up a script for a
film because i wanted to do i was
thinking about a spy idea that was very
similar i found the script online i put
the movie on
on amazon prime and followed the script
with the movie i don't need to do that
but i did it anyway just to follow the
beats and and you know see what got shot
what then that's a great exercise for
people because sometimes the script you
can see what's in it and what's not but
i'm like this has already been done for
me it's a different story i have a
completely different idea of a different
story but this spy movie was awesome so
i'm just gonna watch
you know where all the beats happen and
the formula is there because
you know making a film is like a pop
song it's there in the box it's two
hours long or 90 minutes to two hours
you know you're not reinventing the
wheel
we were talking off camera about the
exorcist and friedkin and bill blatty
and i think you just mentioned something
about rhythm and and i remember that
billboard talked about good writing has
a rhythm
we talk about that in terms of
screenwriting yeah you have to um really
understand the rhythm of a of a film
like think of it like you know you
you've we've all seen lots of films you
have to think of it like
here's the opening where do we go now
then what do you see next then when do
you go back to that character then when
do you see you know the bad guys show up
for the first time you innately you
should understand those rhythms because
they've been done time and time again
you know maybe that script wasn't
originally written like that but when
they shot it they edited it like that
but
there's a rhythm to films which is an
any good film in any successful film you
know which you have to kind of pay
attention to like you don't stay with
one character i mean if it's a character
study that's a little different
but if it's an action film you don't
stay with character a
you know through the whole movie you
know you have to go see the bad guy you
have to go set up what's going on here
you have to go do this and you have to
have this like understanding of rhythm
because
the rhythm on the page is what's going
to get you to the next level you know
the directors is going to make the movie
and he's going to edit it but if you
don't have that those beats in time
you know and you spend six pages with
one guy talking about something people
reading it are just going to tune out so
you have to have this like really
phonetic rhythm of like that happens and
when to end on a scene be like that's a
great beat to end on
cut away to somebody's doing something
else you know cleaning up a dead body
what it was whoa you know catching the
next scene and keeping the rhythm going
where somebody's reading they're like
okay okay okay okay
so
really good filmmakers you know do that
in the films but you can apply it to
your script as well
can you name three films that has have
an excellent example of rhythm that a
new geez um
there's like i just said there's a
million um
i mean you know one one guy who's really
good at rhythm is matthew vaughn like if
you watch his movies like everything
from layer cake to like the um you know
kingsman movies those things have just a
rhythm you know it's like we go here we
do that we introduce this we do
introduce that we introduce this but
there's always
you know two scripts i always tell
people to to watch i mean sorry two
films if you want to learn about
screenplay writing and and they sound
corny but they're two of the best like
films to understand how scripts work one
of them is karate kid
because the first 10 minutes of that
movie you know so much about the
characters and it's so organic
i mean even when daniel larusso shows up
at his new house with his suitcases he
has to kick the gate in and he goes yeah
and then
the kid behind the gate gets knocked
over goes do you know karate i know
karate you know you know it's so simple
and so easy to understand all the
characters you you see
what happens to them or what they're
doing and you understand the characters
and within 15 minutes you know everybody
in the movie what they're about you know
how did they introduce mr miyagi mr
miyagi oh the sink's broke can you go
find the handyman so it's very natural
and organic and quick
that movie just goes
so you know those are all in place
and then the other film i always tell
people watch is urban cowboy because
that has such a great rhythm
of like
almost
using no exposition it just kind of goes
okay he's leaving at this house to go
live here he's going to do this he's
going to do that he meets this girl they
get in a fight and the next thing you
see is it's their wedding and they're
taking photos it's just got this this
pacing that explains so much without
bogging you down in exposition
so
that's kind of what rhythm you know you
have to really pay attention so those
are two more movies that are really good
with the rhythm
do you think a lot of new screenwriters
they get too hung up on one character
you were saying before like you have to
keep it moving yeah not not only that
but they get hung up on like id things
they want to see in a movie you know
that's a big turning point when you're
writing professionally you have to
realize that like you know what that
cool scene you want to write
and you put in the script it's not going
to work and you have to take it out
because there'll be things where like
you it gets stuck in your head you have
to kill i mean kill your darlings you've
heard it time and time again but it's
true you have to do whatever's right to
service the script
and sometimes it's like you might have
written this like amazing intro that you
love
but does nothing for the story
so it's got to go or you have to do
another one but you have to like do that
and i mean look there's directors i've
worked i've worked with some great
directors i work with some directors
that like
want to do something so they're wedging
stuff into the script and it always goes
sideways you know it's like
they saw somebody who did like you know
long runners and just in a movie
recently and they're like well let's
take these five scenes and make it a
one-shot scene and then it screws the
story up
but they don't care because it's like
they want to see it so you can't get
caught up in like things you want to do
and see
you know that don't work for the story
what do you say to the screenwriter who
says it's not their job to get the movie
made
it's just their job to have ideas and
come up with a story
they probably won't get any movies made
um
i mean it's it's a team process it's
like
if you get to a certain level where you
can get paid very well for screenplays
you can have that mindset you know but
those are high level professionals that
are like yeah you know i got paid a half
million dollars to do this and that and
good luck and they know it's a money gig
and maybe it might get made maybe it
won't but if you want to like work more
in the you know 10 million under like
indie film trenches you've got to like
really you know
be part of the process or you know what
happened you'll just be cut out of it
completely you know they'll they won't
ask you and then you know you'll watch a
movie
and this has happened to me it's
something that i worked on that like i
wasn't really part of the pro and you
don't it's not even your script it's not
your story and your name's on it
so it's it's in your best interest to
stay involved in the process and to be a
team player and
you know nobody wants to deal with a
negative writer either if you're like no
those ideas are bad or that's bad you
have to kind of frame it in a way that
like
that's good what about this oh yeah you
know you because
you have to become very you know if
you're going to do this for a living you
have to not
let criticism affect you you have to
just be like okay if somebody doesn't
like something no big deal because
other people that don't do this all the
time like some producers and some actors
and stuff they're very precious about
their ideas and can get very emotionally
hurt if you just go no that's bad so you
have to like be a little bit of a you
know a therapist and you know
and somebody who understands what the
other people are thinking why they're
even asking these things
because i one of the best things i ever
learned was this one actor i'm not gonna
say it was had a really bad idea on this
movie and kept saying it over and over
and it made no sense and i said the
director one day i was like why does he
keep talking about this bad idea and the
director said look he goes guys like us
we have a hundred ideas a day we throw
away 99. guys like him has one idea
every six months he can't let it go and
that was a big light bulb it's like well
that's why he likes that bad idea
because he doesn't have any other ideas
so
you have to kind of manage that and
be part of the process or they'll just
leave you behind they'll just go make
the movie without you
do you literally have like a hundred
ideas i mean are you
let's say in line waiting with a mask
to let you let into the grocery store
and you're like oh wait you know what
that lady reminds me of this that would
make the perfect sense i i probably come
up i'm not kidding i'd probably come up
with at least
10 ideas for films a week if not more
and write them down and some are you
know
just some
have legs you have to kind of like i
have a system where i try to figure out
if it's actually a story or script but
uh yeah i come up with them all the time
like i mean literally all the time there
used to be a joke pitch
that
uh my writing partner i used to do
sometimes to lighten the room when we'd
be just in a meeting you know we'd say
oh we got this idea for this movie it's
like it's point break on motorbikes and
the cyclones are coming in and yeah or
the tornadoes are coming in they have to
rob the banks before tornadoes hit and
this fbi agent has to infiltrate the
group it was a joke idea somebody sold
that exact same script for like a half a
million dollars a few years later like
no i don't think they stole our id or
anything it's just in the ether but
it's what seemed like a joke idea is
somebody else you know so it's like you
have to have a lot of ideas and you have
to know like what ideas are gonna work
because they're i've worked on a few
scripts that are great fantastic scripts
and nobody wants to make them because
there's just this issue or that issue
the producers think it's too hard it
won't make its money back so it's a it's
a balance between the business side and
the creative side
so when you do have a great idea what is
your process for
at least putting it somewhere that you
can come back to and and how do you know
whether you want to take it further i
usually i email them to myself so i have
all these random emails that that half
the time don't make sense like you know
you know second act on on a plane giant
fight you know
guy loses his wife you know hitman finds
out his ex-wife is married to somebody
else yeah things like that so i have all
these weird random things but then once
i really dig in i have a process to
figure out if something can be a script
and usually it's
i figure out the entire first act beat
by beat by beat like the first 20 pages
this happens that happens this happens
like the first six or seven scenes
then i know what happens
in the second hack turn kind of what
shifts the movie or the story and then
how it ends
and if i can figure all that out then i
know i pretty much can write a pretty
good script
so that's usually what i do first i
don't want to know the whole story beat
by beat by beat because i figured some
things out along the way that i would
have never thought of now there's other
times i've kind of thought the whole
thing out almost
you know in in more you know
bigger beats and bigger sections but
that's usually what i do is i know the
first act how it ends what happens in
the middle and then what happens at the
end and that's it
so it starts as an idea you could be
pumping gas somewhere and you go
quickly and email yourself
this little like log line or whatever
and then from there on a weekend maybe
when you have quote spare time you go
and try to do the first 20 pages yeah
usually the ideas that
that i can't stop thinking about
are the ones i know are good they keep
popping back in my head because there's
some ideas you you know just come up
with nah throw it away you know it's
pretty good but it's not great but the
ones that keep reoccurring
you know are the ones that you know
i feel like okay i gotta work on this
there's something here because it's
stuck in my head and also too you know
ideas are great testing ground with
people too
i mean this is for more like commercial
type films but if you can pitch an idea
in two three sentences
you know um to somebody just your
friends or whoever and they kind of do
this weird thing i've noticed this is
when you have a good idea not when
people go that's great when they think
about it for about three seconds and
they go oh that's good that's when you
know it's actually connecting with
people
so you know if you have an idea and you
say that to 10 people and they kind of
all go or they ask you about it again
later you know it's a good idea
so if i tell you i have this great
script about my uncle and he's really
cool he has a pawn shop in hoboken and
he's just a really funny guy
and he always knows when some fence is
coming in to like you know and yeah
and i look at you and you go what are
you going to tell me
if you want to take the time to write
that um but no i mean it might be the
greatest script ever but you know i've
noticed that's one thing i've noticed
too is that the screenplays that get a
lot of traction and get a lot of
people's interest or things that can be
described in two three sentences because
a lot of times
if you're pitching the idea or a
creative exec reads it they have to go
down the hall and pitch it to their boss
so it's too complicated it's going to
get lost in translation so if it's
something that you know we saw the tv
show that like everybody understood the
pitch in two sentences i think that's
why it kept just snowballing and
snowballing because
it was like okay great everybody got it
without reading the pilot without you
know it was like okay good you know
so those kind of things seem to really
work with people at least getting you
through the front door if the scripts
bad it's not gonna go anywhere but you
have to make things
digestible for people too that are
working you have to keep in mind
producers real producers are working
like 20 30 projects in development
hearing pitches all day talking about
things working on films if you give them
some overly complicated
you know idea about your uncle in a pawn
shop they're going to be like wait
what'd you say again like 10 minutes
later
so
there's that
how long after selling your first
screenplay did you sell your second
it happened pretty quick
because
um the next screenplay i don't know if
it was the next thing we wrote but i'd
come up one day i was at the
tower records the old one that used to
have a video you could rent videos and
dvds sunset yes
they had two the one across the street
the one that you know had the dvd store
in it and i was looking at dvds i was
like
i had this idea it was like dario gento
i saw his he had a section i was like
his movies are cool and you know i
watched a lot of his movies from the 70s
it's like we should do a retro kind of
dario magento film and that was when
horror was really hitting its peak in
like 2007 2008 so it's like let's just
write like a 70s jello type
you know
thing that has all those tropes and just
have fun with it and we did and
literally like i don't know how this
happens
is like two months later this friend of
mine who's from italy goes oh you have
something like dario's movies i'll send
it to dario or like um like okay i
didn't really know this guy that well so
and then i get a call like a week later
and star agendo on the phone from italy
he's like i love your script i want to
do it
so
that movie got made i don't the universe
just wanted that movie to get made we
had a lot of problems with the
production um but
it was just strange it was like one day
it's like and sometimes the universe
just kind of leads you in right in
certain directions because i just was
like you know i like his movies let's do
something like his a retro you know 70s
throwback film
and then he literally directed it and
adrian brody was in it so you know it's
how does this happen you know from from
the concept of being in that video store
like a year later i was in italy on set
so
sometimes things you know just have a
weird synergy projects have a weird
synergy too that's the other thing
people have to realize it's happened to
me on so many where i'm banging my head
trying to get this movie made and it's
just not working and then sometimes you
write something and every step of the
way it just snows balls it it connects
at the right time and right place i
don't know why but it just does and that
did
and it's about a missing model
yeah because that's what all the 70s
movies were about like missing pretty
girls so it it leaned into all those
tropes of
it it was like this this girl who was a
model went missing her sister's looking
for her in a you know and doesn't speak
the language and finds this american
who actually does and helps her out so
yeah you know the movies uh cut some
problems but it was it was fun to make
and it was a great adventure and dario's
an amazing person and a great director
another again i've been i feel like i've
had the million dollar film school
because i've got to work with so many
great people
so
yeah so that was that was that taught me
a lot about how things can go wrong on a
movie which
i'm not going to go into too much detail
but a lot of stuff went wrong mostly
with the money
and
the budgets and we didn't have as much
money to finish the film so halfway
through you find that out it's like it's
it was a real a lot of problems
not creatively but
on the business end of the film
was it filmed in italy yeah oh i see
okay yeah great wow it looks like a good
i gotta go to italy for three months
yeah that's nice that was fun to sell a
screenplay do you have to really believe
you can sell it
yeah
yeah i think you need to believe in in
the in the screenplay you have to
believe in
yeah because it's a hustle especially if
it's your first one so you need to
really believe in it it needs to be
something that
you believe in something that you think
you can sell and you just need to be
kind of
relentless but if it doesn't work out
you need to move on to the next script
because the question is you need to ask
yourself
as an up-and-coming screenplay writer if
you want to do this for a living do you
want to write things for yourself to
direct do you want to be a working
screenwriter because if you're if you
get to the level where
you're taking jobs which has happened to
me on several projects i'm getting hired
to write something you know there's like
an adaptation of a book or a comic book
so i don't have any say in the creative
thing but you know you can get paid very
well to like do that work so are you
doing it for yourself are you doing it
because you want to constantly write now
if you want to do it as a living you
know
in that sense where you're writing all
the time you don't get to choose all the
time what you want to write you know you
may have to do a rewrite you may have to
do this so it becomes more about work
than like
you know just believing just in the
project you have to believe in yourself
and it becomes more about like just
doing the work and doing the work
correctly and
efficiently and you know on time
so when things haven't panned out have
you had like a heart to heart with
yourself like well you know i didn't
really believe in it
yeah no i think because most
those those projects
i'll get rid of them before they get to
that point like i won't finish them or
even if i do i'll be honest about like i
don't think everybody's gonna want to
buy this i think it's great
you know but
no one's going to want to make it
because the other thing too is like you
have to really realize that
in regards to indie films or smaller 10
million under film the only way they're
really going to get financed unless you
have a rich uncle is that you have to
have actors in them you have to name
actors that finance the film you can't
just ask somebody for five million
dollars and say
the guy from you know vampire diaries
who's the fifth lead is gonna be the
lead in it it's not gonna work they're
gonna wanna you know name actor they're
going to be like okay we want frank
grillo and we want john travolta we want
you know to
make sure that we can make our money
back so you have to also think too is
that project appealing to actors that
will get your movie made
because that's a big important you know
component to the whole process
so
you've been in situations where you
think you like it but you don't think
others will or a producer well how do
you know that that's the case just
instinct just kind of knowing what you
know and it might not be the right time
to put something out too
you know because it's like okay these
movies are hot you know horror movies
are hot right now all anybody wants to
make are these so you just have to be
really honest with yourself and you know
it you can send it but you only have so
many shots of like getting people to
read things too if you keep sending them
junk
you know
you're not gonna get anywhere even even
i'm very careful never to send my agents
and managers too much stuff
because i'll be like oh that was okay
you know so i only try to send them the
best stuff that i do
can you think of a screenplay of yours
that you did not think would sell
and did
yes
broken vows
which
was made with jamie alexander and wes
bentley
um
yeah it was just it was a script that
my writing partner and i wrote and then
we weren't really too happy with it we
knew it was good but it wasn't great and
we just kind of stuck it in a drawer and
then i got a call like
two or three years later from a producer
friend of mine said hey do you got
anything that can be made for two and a
half million dollars and we're looking
for a thriller or something in that
genre so i was like yeah here we we
never sent this out we never gave it to
our agent even to read
um check it out it's good you know we
could maybe work on a little bit more
make it better
um
and then i get called like a week later
like okay cool we got the financing
let's make it
so that was like literally like
just finding a movie in a drawer because
it was just sitting in a file
but
i also think two part of that is that
goes back to what i'm saying about
some of the stuff that i think is not up
to to par it's still i've written some
some things that are very professional
and could get made but i don't want to
like take my shots with those because i
just think they're not
you know maybe they're 90 they're not
100. so i think even something that on
my 90 because i've worked on so many
things is still good enough to turn into
a film the opportunity just arose that
this was a good opportunity to take that
film that was like 90 there and they
were looking for something like that
so it worked great
did you think it was too edgy
no it just seemed
i don't know i don't know why it just
didn't it didn't even click with the
writers in some ways we knew it was good
but it didn't click with us
but then we worked out a little bit more
once it got serious and then it became a
different kind of film and became a
little bit better
so i don't know it was just a weird
situation where uh
it was just script was sitting in a
drawer and ended up getting fully
financed and made with great actors and
you know i think the actors brought a
lot to it too
so it was one of those projects that and
that's what you always want is your
screenplay can be here but hopefully the
the finished products one step better
sometimes it goes the other direction
where you know i have one movie which
i'm not going to say which movie
which everybody who saw in the film
business was a screenplay was great
you know which that's very disheartening
you know when
it should get a step or two better when
when it's shot and edited and made into
a film
broken vowels was like uh
like a
romantic deception or yeah what was it
um sorry it's been a while um yeah it
was like a stalker movie but the guy was
a stalker you know usually you saw it as
as the girls the stalker now they've had
quite a few of those i think we wrote it
like 2008 and then it got made in 2013.
so it was it was that the guy was like
obsessed with the woman and i mean
they've made quite a few of those since
then so
and it was wes bentley that yeah the
obsessed oh yes yeah yeah he's great
great to work with great guy
so
yeah
and so from that time that you got that
call where they said hey what do you got
hanging around
when was the movie actually finished
what was the time for him probably about
a year later and we had to do the post
everybody chipped in i did the sound mix
the other producer did the color timing
so you know it took a little bit longer
to get made but yeah so it was made and
i think lion's gate lines get
distributed so
so when they said what do you have you
said well i've got this thing and you
kind of were almost talking them out of
it before no just i didn't know what
they were really looking for so it was
just it was like okay you've got this
certain amount of money that you want to
invest in a film you're looking for this
type of film
um but i did tell them from the get-go i
was like this is the kind of film we can
easily cast because it's got some good
parts
you know for actors and they're you know
between 25 and 35 which is a really good
spot to find some good actors and we did
what no bs screenwriting advice can you
give to young screenwriters or even
older who've never sold something and
think that they can make a living at
this well you gotta really be realistic
you have to look at the steps involved
if
and what is your uh end game you know do
you want to get a movie made it's a
small movie what kind of movie is it are
you writing a kind of studio type script
are you writing kind of a you know a
small intimate thing that can be made
for you know half a million dollars so
you have to kind of set the parameters
of what you want to do
you know and kind of take it from there
because
if you're a young screenwriter and you
want to do this for a living
i mean you need to write a couple
samples and write some scripts you know
you need to be around the film business
you know tv's given a lot of
opportunities to you know being on
writing staff there's so many tv shows
now too that's a great way to becoming a
writer you can become a writer's
assistant get to know the the working
writers
you know and you'll actually get paid
taking notes doing things and learn how
it all works and that that will help you
with jobs if you're a little bit older
i mean you should really work on
you know work on your screenplays but
also determine what do you want to do is
it something that you want to
try to get made on your own do you want
to try you know like it's a little bit
different are you writing a john wick
movie or are you writing a
you know small intimate thing because if
it's a john wick movie that means you
have to sell it through the studio
system that's very hard to break into
until you like are working at a certain
level it does happen but you usually
have to work your way up you don't just
you know all of a sudden you're not up
for like these gigantic jobs of writing
you know 100 billion dollar films so
that's that's a whole kind of
skill set into itself
so my advice would be just just keep
working but work on your craft because
people don't do that they don't you know
they don't take the time to actually
keep rewriting and learning to write you
know they write one thing and they think
here it is world
you know and that that's why it doesn't
get made and then they get frustrated
but i think
anybody who's going to take if you're
determined and you want to take
you know 10 years of your life working
super hard to get somewhere you can get
somewhere you get some movies made you
can you can do it for a living but you
have to really like
buckle down and be like okay am i gonna
like
save enough money for a year that's kind
of what i did i said i'm just gonna save
enough money so i don't have to work for
your focus on this or just
really you know and being in la is a big
part of it too it really is you know
unfortunately it's like
it's hard to become
you know a professional screenwriter
when you're in missouri or somewhere
because a lot of the connections you
make and people you meet
you know i ran into a friend of mine
who's a big producer at the coffee bean
one day i hadn't seen her a while and
she said what do you what are you
working on i go well we got this zombie
thing and she goes oh call me later and
then we got paid to write it for for a
huge company so it's like but those are
relationships i developed for a long
time but if i wasn't in la i would have
ran into her you know it's it's these
are just things that you know happen
and
you know so it's that's another part of
it too so you have to be in the gate you
have to be around it you can't just you
know be
outside of it because there's a lot to
learn a lot of people to meet it's all
about relationships too
what year was this that you had saved up
the money so that you could live for a
year i think it was 2005. oh okay so the
economy was doing well so yeah i
produced i produced a movie with david
boreanas
and then i did a big music video and and
got paid well on both those so it's like
okay now's the time
so um
yeah because i didn't want to keep
producing films because producing
producing is fun i like producing but
it's different
it's not that creative
so i was just like now's the time so
what i did is i just planned for a whole
year it's like okay i'm just going to
focus on this and it worked but i'd
worked around i'd been in the business
and worked in the business and knew
people so it wasn't
you know coming out from somewhere
moving to l.a in a small apartment just
going okay i got a year to make it but
you know if you want to do it you can do
it it's not the good thing about
screenwriting it doesn't take a ton of
money to do it you don't it's i mean if
you want to make a short film
that you have to hire a crew you have to
shoot you know to write you know even
the other day a really big a-list
director not to say it was he goes
writing's free
you know if you want to just sit and
write and do as many drafts you want you
it's your time but it doesn't cost you
anything
so day one of that like we're doing this
i'm not you know i'm not taking any new
commitments on
what was your did you like schedule
things out did you have it on a calendar
today no i wish i was that i wish i was
that organized it was a lot of intuition
just like okay now feels like the time
you know so no it wasn't i wish it was
more planned out but you know sometimes
you know some of this stuff just happens
but you have to be in the game for it to
happen you know i put myself in the
situation where it's like okay this is
all i'm gonna do and just talk to people
about it you know
annoyed
agents that i knew i was like hey i
wrote the script i'm working on the
script and they didn't care you know
even though i knew them you know they're
like great good luck
but i was like okay this is the time now
to be really focused
on on
just and not really having a plan b
and how many hours a day did you write
during that year
probably like
three or four
but i think after four hours you get a
little bit like diminished returns now
that doesn't mean the other
five or six hours a day i'm not thinking
about the writing like but physically
sitting there behind the keyboard
usually you try to limit to like four
hours because after four hours you start
getting if the work starts getting a
little like
you know not there you know you're not
sharp
why keep writing but i'm always thinking
about things like a lot of things when i
write i don't touch keyboard until i've
figured out the whole for like i said
the whole first act the second act turn
and i will i can sit down one day and
write 20 pages but i've thought about it
for two or three weeks
and maybe just wrote out and beats
what's going to happen
and then you know it's not the best 20
pages in the world but i could do it one
day
in a couple hours but i know where
everything's going to fit and what the
beats are and then i'll go back and
rewrite the dialogue and rework the
scenes but i know what's going to
so after a year did you say okay time to
start making money again or you it just
naturally progressed it started
happening oh okay yeah
so
got lucky in that sense very nice and
then that film you ended up selling it
yeah the second the second script we
wrote second script oh yeah yeah that
was the one that didn't get made but
yeah i got paid for that and that was a
nice that was a good feeling i would
think that was the first time i ever got
paid to be creative you know i've been
i've worked on films but that's a little
bit different kind of creativity you
know as being a producer
but being creative it was it's like the
greatest feeling in the world to like
do something creative and get paid well
for it you're like what this actually
you can actually do this and that's a
that's a big inspiration once you get
that once it becomes kind of a rush it's
like oh hey
this is better than working at starbucks
not that i ever worked but you know or
you know going to an office
yeah much better than going to an office
yeah
did you have office jobs no no i mean in
the film industry i did i always i was
very lucky i just but i always kind of
angled myself to where i had a cool job
because i
didn't want to
be bored at work that was like the only
mantra i had it was like i don't want to
be bored
what do you think makes you different
from the other
screenwriters who have come to hollywood
during the same time
where you've been able to make a career
at this and possibly they haven't
i think understanding the business
because i i was in the business part of
it first and producing and and just
knowing
like how distribution works knowing like
what they you know how how actors sell
films and things like that because it
just you kind of can filter it through a
different kind of lens where it's like
okay this is what people are looking for
because i've been to afm i've been to
can i've been to you know sundance on
the business side of it so you know you
see all those posters you see what kind
of movies they're trying to put together
and you also see how many movies are
being put together you know it's like
astronomical if you go to afm how many
films are you know tens of thousands of
them and maybe you know a finite number
of those get made
but you see a reoccurring theme and you
kind of understand how these people work
you know and it just depends on on what
kind of like
you know
level you're at to studio level is
completely different i'm talking more
about the indie world you know but
breaking into the studio world is very
difficult as well he said you have to
work your way up on that so i think that
gave me advantage that was just
understanding
um
the business and i can also put myself
in the mindset of a producer when i'm
writing something and i know okay the
producer's not gonna like that but
they'll like this
so that helps
where someone else may have come out but
they had no prior film
industry experience and so
even though it's a very personalized
story it just won't
work because it doesn't tick these
different boxes exactly and and like
who's going to be like like we talk
about the the movie about your uncle who
runs a
you know a pawn shop
you know what actor is dying to play
that part that can finance a film and
then that turns into a whole other
conversation all together because
there's so few actors at certain levels
that can finance a film that's the
reason you see so many bruce willis
movies nick cage movies you know john
travolta movies there's not a big pool
of people that can justify people
spending 5 10 20 million dollars
so that's part understanding that's a
big part of it as well
how does genre factor in getting a movie
made well this is a very important thing
too to remember is that
the reason you see so many action films
on uh netflix and things like that is
because action films and thrillers
translate internationally if you want to
make a comedy
and it's a comedy about a bunch of kids
in new jersey and and you know
they're going through their last summer
before they graduate high school and
there's a bunch of jokes about you know
american kids in jersey that's not going
to translate in like malaysia they're
not going to understand it so those
movies have no very little international
value but now action and thrillers
sci-fi and horror is like an
international language that's why you
see so many of those films because they
can sell not only in america but all
around the world and that's also
something you need to keep in mind if
you have this small intimate
you know film that you want to make
about the screenplay that's about you
know four sisters in ohio
and it's a comedy drama it's like you've
got a very small audience for that
so you know that's why producers don't
like things like that and that's why
when you look you can see so many of
those action thrillers on netflix
because they make money internationally
but what if it's in someone's heart i
don't mean to sound so cheesy but what
if it's what if it's in someone's
dna that they just want to make a
coming-of-age story and to them they
have to get that story out there and
they want to finish it
well i mean if
if you're a screenwriter like that
that's got that story i think you should
become a filmmaker if it's that that
story is like figure out a way to make
the 10 000 version of that or the 50 000
version of it and make it
you know that's that's the thing is like
you've probably got a better chance of
like
cobbling together your friends and
making a decent movie of that and maybe
getting in some film festivals getting
noticed like that then just sending your
script out to people
so that's what i would suggest you know
now that takes money and resources but
if that's your passion project you know
spend a few years you know putting
together all those resources or figure
out a way to shoot it there's you know
there's great films that have been made
for ten thousand dollars you know you
just have to understand how filmmaking
works that's a whole nother conversation
altogether but you can do it
i think we've already touched on this
but is it correct that you didn't get an
agent until you sold your first script i
had a manager
and then um
when we sold the second script there was
article about the hollywood reporter and
then literally that next morning
there was like 10 agents called now you
don't always need here's the thing is
agents are great but they're not a magic
bullet for your career either
you know they do things for you and
managers do too but you have to do a lot
on your own you have to meet producers
you have to get out there you have to do
things
um
and i think actually part of that what
got the ball rolling on that that film
was was people really dug the script but
i think the reason we got involved with
those producers because i'm forgetting
some of this stuff is a friend of mine
who'd worked with me on a film that i
had produced
who was a production coordinator was now
working for them as a development exec
and she was like you should check out
their script so it all kind of tied
together from one thing into another so
it's all about those relationships again
what was the title of the article
dom just it was one of those generic
sold sold a script you know but back to
the agent manager thing it's like
you know they're great to have but they
they work you know they only have so
much resources to give you you can't
like rely on them for everything even if
they care and they they take the time to
read but they have 20 other clients so
you have to like
really understand
you know what
how to use them as well have a
relationship where because they they're
both they have a bottom line you know
they have to make money too so a lot of
people think oh i just want an agent
manager but you have to think what are
you providing them are you selling
things do you have things you can sell
you know are they going to take you on
as a client and build your career so
where are you in the process as well
what do you provide for them
and so when you got those calls the next
day how did you know who which person
you wanted to go with or or even
entertain going with you you have
meetings and you meet with them
and then you kind of just decide you
know who's
who's the correct person you know based
on based on instinct and and also too um
yeah chemistry and and also the manager
will kind of push you in that right
direction too we had a manager at the
time and they were like hey you know our
manager said i've got some other clients
with
with him and you know so it's all very
there's a lot of synergy there when you
got those calls and i'm assuming it
wasn't like you woke up and then your
phone's buzzing it's like one of those
no it's not like that hey jim this is so
you know so but how did were you like
this is happening like i've
i've made it
i mean it felt good to have an agent but
it felt good to have a manager too but
you quickly learned that like you know
you've got to do the work it's like okay
well you sold something
that you know they weren't part of so
they didn't get commission so they're
like what's next you know and so it's
like you've got to get back on the
treadmill and start like figuring things
out and doing things
anytime we interview someone they
naturally go right away to their imdb
for better or worse and they they want
to vet the person so you have i believe
six screenwriting credits okay can you
talk about how many you've written and
how screenwriting actually works and how
selling them actually works so you have
six there but
probably you have many more that just
aren't on your imdb yeah um that's a
good question is
i mean there's i've probably written i
don't know maybe 80 screenplays
um probably optioned or been hired to
write at least 20 or 25 i don't even
know anymore but um
the thing is that there's different
things too it's like sometimes you can
be hired to write it write a script you
know we wrote a script for antoine fuqua
who hired us to write this movie about
the lapd so sometimes you're hired those
don't get made and then you don't they
don't show up on you know your imdb
credits or you get hired to write a
pilot i've written several pilots for tv
shows that haven't been made too um you
know and then sometimes things are
optioned you know or people buy things
they don't get made so it's always
different but you know um
so that's probably the you know i don't
know there's been a lot the thing is i
have this rule of thumb to make a living
in the film business i have to have
almost 20 projects in development or i'm
working on at any given time
so whether i'm writing something right
now or have something out there or
producing something or trying to put
something together or something over
here because the formula i think is if i
have 22 of them might get put together
so that's what i'm getting paid off of
so you know because this is how i pay
the bills i have to think like that and
have to have a lot of things going on
but yeah you know that there's a lot of
things a lot of work you do that doesn't
show up on imdb because it's things that
you wrote it didn't get made or were
optioned or you know you got hired to
write and once you get hired to write
something if it doesn't get made you
don't own the script they own it
so i don't know what they're doing with
you know several projects you know we
wrote a really big
teenage zombie thing for qed and they're
not even around anymore so i don't know
who even owns the rights that but we got
paid so someone owns it you know so
there's there's things that happen like
that
so imdb is not a full it doesn't i'm
nothing against imdb but it doesn't
indic it's not a full barometer or it's
not your resume no no exactly like i put
my resume on linkedin like like i've
been hired to write or
you know work on like i don't know at
least 20 things like you know we just
had a tv project that didn't work with a
really big a-list
you know director but we got paid to
write a pilot off of that you know they
had a tv show we sold the abc that
almost got made so you know there's a
lot of things that you know you get paid
you work on but you build those
relationships too with those people
so
do you think most writers want to take
shortcuts
no i don't think so i think
i don't think it's shortcuts but i think
they just don't dig in and do the work
you know writing a script you know
a first draft and just going here you go
world you know it's like you may have to
rewrite it over and over especially when
you haven't done it often you know you
have to learn how things work and you
have to get good at it's like any other
kind of like
craft or anything else you know it's
like you don't become great in two
months
you know you don't you can't ride a bike
amazing in two months or skateboard or
do karate in two months why do you think
you can just write a screenplay and the
world's going to come looking for it you
have to get really good at it
and you have to learn every day and
really watch a lot of people you have to
love films too you have to really be
into films and what's the structure of
films and what are they trying to say in
scenes
and and you know just really be
passionate about it so that's that's my
thing is i don't think they take
shortcuts but they just don't do the
work so maybe that's a gigantic shortcut
but you've got to get good at your crap
you got to keep doing keep rewriting
right if you want to be a professional
right you should have a ton of scripts
you know especially if you're young keep
writing a bunch of things
you'll get everyone's going to get
better
you know most professional writers are
like on their seventh or eighth script
by the time they sell something
you know so they've gotten better each
step of the way and they've taken five
or six years to get good at it
you were in a band correct yeah and what
did you play i played guitar oh okay
okay great and how long did it take you
to pick up different chords and
feel like you could be in front of an
audience
oh the cool thing with the hair yeah
that was so long ago i mean
yeah i don't i don't know i started
playing guitar i was 13 or 14 so it was
but i played in a band called hate
department back then which still are
kind of around and were pretty
successful and great guy and they're
still friends of mine which is even more
amazing all those years later we're
still all good friends
so
yeah it was fun it was
you know
i thought i was gonna be a rock star but
instead i ended up being a screenwriter
but you know so it's not not the worst
thing in the world
is there are there similarities so you
you needed maybe you didn't have to go
to school before you didn't go to gti or
you didn't go to whatever juilliard but
you you learned
different chords you probably listened
and mimicked different songs
yeah a lot of similarities it's funny
you say that because it's about i think
about the rhythm of like things like you
understand rhythm in in
story and just you know same thing with
with music it's like you go here you do
that you go here you do that because you
know we talk about i talked with a lot
of people about like
films you know kind of more popular type
films not the avant-garde kind films or
like pop songs you know they're not that
complicated it's three-act structure
it's all you know there's you hit
certain beats there's this point where
there's heartbreak all hope is lost it's
like a pop song it's very structured you
know it's not like a prog rock thing you
know there's movies like that but those
are few and far between and not the ones
that everybody sees but for the most
part films are very structured and they
they have a rhythm and you know you know
something bad is going to happen here
when you're watching you kind of know
you know you know the pacing of a movie
they're they're all you know you know at
the end
if something happens weird at the end
you're like that can't be the end
because you know you've seen it so many
times in films
and just as music producers know
this is going to be a hit it fits these
different things the same with film yeah
i mean not so much a hit but you know if
it's going to work or not you know get
to some but you know there's things like
i said there's been a few screenplays
we've had out there where i'm like wow
people really like this they've really
responded to it more than i even thought
so
you never know
how do you know they leave comments or
yeah they respond you mean to the
screenplays or yeah yeah right because
you just get yeah no because you just
get uh up for jobs you know they bring
you in for other stuff or they make an
offer to buy it you know or so
so you know that's yeah if it gets you
other work it's doing something
and get you a lot of meetings you read a
great screenplay you have an agent send
it out you can end up with like meetings
all day long
with everybody
is that its own sort of busy work though
where you you're taking so many meetings
but then you're not actually getting the
work done or it's not a bad thing uh
it's building relationships which paid
off in the end
what makes 99 of screenplays unreadable
i think it's it might be the story it
depe probably everyone is there's a
different problem with them but they all
have problems because i've seen a lot of
these but what you need to think about
too is the reader they don't think about
who's reading it and the person reading
it they're a professional
has a stack of scripts you know sky-high
in their office so you need to
understand like
if you don't grab the person the first
two three pages you know and you hear
this all time but
sometimes you even need to like have
something happen that might not happen
like that in the film like you know is
there a scene
you know on page 23 that's super
exciting
okay why not put that
two or three pages or section of it at
the very beginning and then create a
flashback or do something so that the
it's exciting and really reads like a
professional script at the very
beginning and that's the other thing it
has to read like a professional script
which means the dialogue has to be well
executed it has to move it has to have
beats you don't want to get bogged down
in minutia you don't want to you know do
exposition you have to show don't tell
but the thing is it's not hard to get
copies of screenplays nowadays because
the internet has everything so there's a
movie like your movie
see how they did it you know but you
have to really grab people right away it
has to be
you know
professional all the way through but if
it's not professional first five pages
they're just gonna you know be like what
is this you know and you're asking
someone
you know to take an hour two hours of
their life to read your script so it
better be perfect
you know and you better really do your
work
or else you're wasting people's time
is that when a script
consultant might be helpful because
let's suppose everyone you know is going
to just tell you it's great and they've
never
written a movie before yeah a script
consultant could be helpful um
there's some things you just intuitively
either are gonna figure out or you're
not but you know you can you can get a
script consultant to take you maybe to
the next level or show you things you're
doing wrong i said my view on that is is
they're good as long as you don't spend
a lot of money
because i've had people come to me
asking me to fix a script or saying hey
can you do this i spent fifty thousand
dollars on this script i paid somebody
to go to write it and they're like
somebody's never written a script so you
have to be very careful that you don't
you know
lose your ass financially so um
but you know it could help you know
there's so many classes out there
there's so many things but i just always
go back to watch movies they're there
they show you how to do it it's already
been done for you you know and just
figure out how your story fits into that
formula and just kind of like find those
beats
but that's why i think why 99 of scripts
are just they're not ready and they're
not at a professional level you know if
you get there
it takes a lot of work to get it there
and do you think that people gave up too
soon on some of those unreadable scripts
or that there's just no way to sort of
it's just lipstick on a pig you can't
really fix it yeah probably
probably both but i think a lot of it's
just not doing the work you know you
just it's not some magic thing you know
i think people have this you know
you know they envision you know smoking
cigarettes writing in the middle of the
night you know like it's glamorous it's
not glamorous it's like if you really
want to get good at the people who make
a living in it are people who just you
know stick to it you know grind it out
rewrite it rewrite it rewrite it the
other day i found there was a project i
found like i was cleaning out my
computer i found like 40 drafts of the
script
you know it's like that's a lot of
drafts
so you know and that's what you have to
do is really grind it and work on it and
make sure you know you get to
professional level and like i said you
can find all these scripts online you
know if it's anything that's similar you
can find it if you you know you want to
do a movie about
a guy in a food truck
you know john favreau did chef watch
that you know you know by the way he's
one of the best that like
beats in a film watch his films they all
have the same rhythm and the same beats
it's there
yeah i love chef that was great yeah so
you saved each draft of that screenplay
you did it four years yeah 40 drafts and
you saved each one this is
you know just datum now because there's
so many on so many things so yeah what's
the purpose of saving each draft of a
revision just to kind of keep track
you know i mean i probably not really
anything you know that has to do with
screenwriting just that's my process
it's just easier to kind of like you
know i also back everything up on email
and things like that and another backup
but but you know you never know when you
need it or go back to something that
like you took out so i sometimes get a
little crazy to start cutting stuff out
too i can i can like
just chop chop chop and then sometimes i
chop too much
so i'll be like oh wait that was good
what was that one scene where the guy
couldn't aim the gun because he was
shaking i cut that out so i'll go back
to older version and find it just cut
and paste it back in
what really irritates you about reading
other screenplays what irritates me is
just when people haven't done got it to
where it should be at a level of reading
you know where they send you something
and they go oh don't read that wait i
got this one or i changed that or you or
do you read it you talk to them they're
like oh i changed that it's like well
that means you know there was that
famous josh olson article which you can
find online
um about reading people's scripts
which you know it's like if it's not
ready to be read don't send it to me
because it's like like josh had
mentioned it's like asking somebody come
over to your house and paint for two
hours you know you're taking up two
hours of somebody's time you know so
don't give it to them to read until it's
like perfect and there
you know and if you want my notes and i
give you some notes don't be defensive
about it either that's the most
irritating thing it's like don't say i
want i want your opinion and then you
give somebody an opinion and you say you
need to fix this okay great thanks
and they're they have an attitude about
it it's like
you know
why'd you have me read it just tell you
it's great is it okay to question why
you
gave a certain note is that yeah oh yeah
definitely definitely yeah oh yeah of
course and and you know
what do i know as much as i know i don't
know anything so it's like you know
sometimes my notes might not even be
valid it's just this is what i think
you know but sometimes people don't even
want to hear that they just want they
just want you to tell them it's great
did you ever catch that in yourself and
really work on that it sounds like
you're okay with with negative feedback
um
it gets easier
you know some i mean it all kind of
depends on who it comes from too
it's like you know i mean if if somebody
reads a script of mine that's like never
written a script and they
were like i don't like this and that
i mean probably my knee-jerk reaction
like what do you know but
if it's a producer or somebody who i
respect and who's done a lot of work
then i listen to him
but it does get easier to take the
negative feedback and like
like i said before it's about
interpreting notes too sometimes people
can't explain why they don't like
something
and you have to figure that out
would you say that 99 of what hollywood
makes is garbage no
there's some garbage but
but
no i think i think most
films i mean most films get started with
very good intentions
and look i've made a few movies that i'm
not happy with either but the process is
not a singular process you have to deal
with producers actors you know
money guys distributors like even the
nic cage movie that i wrote it wasn't
called rage the distributor called it
rage you know it's like really rage okay
nobody's gonna make fun of rage in the
cage
you know but i had no control over that
so if you lose so much control in the
process
that you know
it takes a very very strong director
like somebody like quentin tarantino who
can say no to everybody and filter out
the bad that comes along you know that's
you know you're making you're doing art
by committee so that's why sometimes
things
they have great intentions maybe it was
a great script maybe the actor was
amazing but things got messed up along
the way because there's so many people's
hands on the editor you know the
composer
the director there's the screenwriter
the producer who shows up on set
and wants to put a motorcycle chase in
the middle of the movie that makes no
sense and then you find out later it's
because he can get a free bmw motorcycle
if we put him in the movie things like
that happen so you know that's why
sometimes movies don't work out but i
think most
screenwriters and directors almost all
of them have the intention to make a
great movies just things get in the way
or lack of money or resources
so if someone's at a certain level then
there's so much more creative control
because they can basically say no to
people you need that like one per that's
why score says you can make but you need
a strong director writer director who
can like no one's going to question that
because then it at least keeps
everything focused there's very few of
those people you know but like i think
paul thomas anderson i don't think any
producers are going to show up or money
guys and tell them what to do you know
so it's
or queen tarantino or christopher nolan
that's why they can make really great
films because the white noise that's
going on around them they can just stop
you know or just ignore it or or people
just scared even you know mess with them
because people want to get their ideas
in a film too you'll have
you know money guys who you've never
even met
who gave some money on a film show up
and like give an idea and then other
ones are great and actually have good
ideas so you know there's just so many
people that are involved in a film that
it's hard sometimes to keep it focused
so i think that's the problem with
things that sometimes because a lot of
movies on netflix you know
look like they had good intentions and
like i said i've i've worked on a few
that like
start off over here and ended up over
there you know
it happens
why don't you outline screenplays well i
think i described before what i like to
do i like to just do all the beats
everything i like to write the first act
have the you know the second act turn
and the the ending because i found that
like if you are too kind of sometimes
too methodical
about figuring it all out up front
uh you can't discover certain things
you know you'll find things that are
happening along the way that are like
surprises even to you and sometimes that
stuff becomes even better you know
you're like oh i didn't think about that
but you know how do i get these guys
from the end of act one to the second
second act turn
and you just discover it i know some
people that like to do a complete beat
sheet you have to do that when you're
hired to write things you know you have
to give them a you can't do that that's
but for a spec purpose or writing a
script you can you know have your own
process
so it feels a little stale sometimes
when you have everything beated out you
know and you're like okay because that
two weeks you're writing out the beat
sheet
you might
get a better sense of your story and
your characters four weeks into writing
the script
and find things along the way that like
oh i never thought about that guy like
that or this like this
do you get bored when things are too
easy
yeah
yeah like a challenge yeah
because i get the sense you figure
things out very easily and so you want
to go to the next level
yeah
especially well i think too you have to
kind of as a screenwriter like reinvent
like where you want to go every couple
years too unless you're you're happy in
the
area the area that you're in so yeah no
i guess i do yeah i never thought of it
like that but yeah i think i'm always
trying to like
reinvent or kind of come to get the next
level or do certain things and figure
out how it works so yeah i do
i like to make things harder myself no
but that you just enjoy a challenge you
know you like to be you you don't it's
kind of like i hate to use like a lab
rat i mean i'm sorry
but you know they they get the cheese
they get out okay they they solve the
thing yeah if you want to really boil it
down to that but we all kind of want
something more because if things are too
easy then it's just
everything's boring and then you can
become depressed yeah and i don't know
where i get it from but i'm really in in
to like getting things finished like
like i think i said earlier i'm never
happy till something's done i enjoy the
process more but i've been on movie
shoots and and things where it's getting
made i'm miserable the whole time
because i'm i still think something's
gonna go wrong you know when it's
finished and then i also have a weird
amnesia when projects are finished i
don't think about them again i just move
on i
think of
most of the films i've worked on that
have been made i've maybe watched once i
don't ever go back watch them or think
about them and john carpenter has that
attribute if you watch the brian de
palma documentary he has that not that
i'm comparing myself to them but it's
like a good thing to have if you're
gonna do this professionally it's like
once you're done with something you just
move on you don't even think about that
old project again it's like what's next
how is someone who doesn't outline so
great at structure
that's a good question i think
i just know how
films work and watch a lot of films and
just just know that the structure will
find itself because like i'm very open
to like okay and i think i always have a
good understanding like tracking
tracking characters is a very important
thing in script you have to make sure
that somebody hasn't disappeared too far
out of the story like if you have a bad
guy in something and he shows up page 20
and then shows up page 40.
he can't disappear until page 90.
we have to see what he's doing at some
point so i i think i always have a
really good understanding of like making
sure we track people and like okay we've
seen this character do this now we have
to go back to that person we have to go
find that person
catch them all up put put them where
they go
so you know
and how do you remember do you almost
have like um bullet points like okay
there's
there's joe over here there's there's
mary and then making sure that i'm i'm
still seeing their names somewhere
within the last few pages
yeah it's it's i don't know it's kind of
easy for me it seems easy i know some
people will like chart out where
characters are and and so everybody has
their own process you know and you can
do note cards and things like that i
kind of always have an idea where
they're coming going and you know and
also too that's also part of you get
better right into you you throw away any
characters that don't mean anything to
the story you know if you're a newer
writer and you have all these characters
that don't mean anything you're going to
have a hard time tracking people but if
you really pay attention to films
especially commercial ones they don't
have a lot of
characters there might be a lot of
people in it but it centers around a
small group of people you know the
godfather might be one thing but i mean
if you look at indiana jones you know
it's always just him and then they'll go
to the bad guys and then they kind of
like you're along the journey with him
so it's yeah it's more like about
tracking those people but most studio
films don't have a lot of people
marvel films aside you know when the
avengers have like 8 000 characters but
even then if you watch the avenger
movies they're great at tracking all
those different people
you know they keep coming going out of
the story just enough so you don't
forget them
what about something like crash
crash that's a little bit different but
um
that's you know
yeah that's that's more the extreme but
i mean but i mean that's a kind of
different film you know the still is
anchored though by you know it's
anchored more by stories
you know
so yeah that's a good example but that's
a little bit different that's you know
and i don't know how many
kind of movies like that they're doing
nowadays because that was kind of hit
for a while you know the non-linear
bouncing around all these multiple
stories
so
yeah that's a different kind of movie
right but it works you know yeah it was
excellent um can you provide a few
questions that a screenwriter or
producer should ask themselves before
writing a movie or or getting involved
with a movie yeah i think the biggest
question is how do i get made
you know if it's if it's you know some
kind of gigantic sci-fi epic that cost
400 million dollars
you know it's it's like a non-starter
but i think you just need to really ask
you have to be passionate about it too
and really you know want to see it to
the finish line because it takes a lot
of work i mean you want to get paid
but you know money's your main drive
that's not always you know
what happens there's things i've worked
on and worked on them so long that even
though i got paid well i probably end up
making you know a dollar an hour dollar
fifty you know if you timed it out but
it was like i was like i'm determined to
get this film finished so
i think that's the biggest question
because why write something if you're
not going to try to really get it made
or use it to get other jobs or create a
career you know if it's just for your
friends to read that's a whole other
thing all together
how many films do you think have been
made where
they were too ambitious in terms of the
budget and and oh lots people just
couldn't be told no that happens all the
time and i mean it just happens in the
sense that like
you start and you something goes wrong
because with indie films the budgets are
so
precise that if something goes wrong it
could screw the whole movie up you don't
get to shoot that you now it's not 25
days it's 20 days you know there's so
many things that can go wrong but i
think that's where that has very little
do with the screenplay but more to do
with the director being able to like
change things and adjust things on the
fly and go okay that we can cut that out
we can move that to there and we can
save this whole thing and not make have
it be a mess but it happens a lot
so if you are hired for a screenplay and
you do have to do a beat sheet and you
submit it and then a couple weeks later
you come up with better ideas
are you stuck with that that same beat
sheet and that same progression no you
can i mean what you can do is is if
you're hired to write something you have
to communicate you know with the
producers because every step is tiered
it's like you get paid to start you get
paid when you turn in the beat sheet or
the treatment you get paid to start
writing the script but if you start
coming up with changes or figure things
out you can just you know get the
producers on the phone who who have paid
you to write it and throw your ideas at
them and they may love them they might
they might just say stick with the beach
they might say oh that's great let's try
that so it's a process you know you you
have to be in really good communication
when you're taking money from people and
working with somebody and keep them
informed but you can't make wholesale
changes and go here it is
because
your agent will be calling you go why
are they calling me all pissed off and
you did this wrong you know so you have
to kind of like
you have to do what they want they're
hiring you to do something it's like if
they hired you to paint the house you
know gray you can't paint it red you
know and say oh i thought this section
would look better like this so
you're their employee but you know you
get the job by coming in with your own
take
and your own pitch which they like but
then it becomes theirs when they start
paying you and then you just have to
work with them you know but yeah most
great producers if you come up with a
great idea you just run it by them
they're like oh that's much better so
they're not resistant to it but you have
to
you can't just decide to go in the third
act a totally different way
would you say a lot of screenwriters
fail because they're not writing movies
that hollywood wants to make yeah i mean
you have to like it goes back to what
it's talking about with like you know
the business side of it you have to make
money for people you know it's not it's
not a
situation where people just trying to
throw money away or light it on fire so
if you cannot create a screenplay that
like producers think they can at least
get their money back and some because
sales agents take a cut everybody takes
a cut so you have to actually make some
profit on top of it
someone along the line is going to lose
money
and that's not what most people want to
do you know there's like i said there's
some
billionaires that just want to throw
money at things and and don't care but
those are few and far between so i think
yeah you have to be very honest with
yourself about what people are buying
you know you can't make some weird
you know film that like
speaks to you and your small group of
friends and expect somebody to give you
a million dollars to make it and no one
else gets it
and the universal appeal that you had
talked about previously just sci-fi
horror in action well that has foreign
appeals so yeah that that's part of the
process too like you have to keep in
mind that like the form the the foreign
mark there's two markets the domestic
market which is you know north america
and then the foreign market which is the
rest of the world
that you know what a you know some movie
about
skateboarders in hollywood you know
in love might not translate in in you
know japan the same way a horror movie
would or a thriller so you it that
that's a whole nother section of money
that comes in on a film
so yeah it becomes harder and harder the
more esoteric something is now that's
where sometimes the greatest movies come
from you know like gasparno makes insane
crazy you know esoteric movies that that
do really well and are cool
but
again those are few and far between and
in america i think
they're less likely to take chances and
europe i've worked with a few european
producers and they seem a little bit
more you know into the art they also
treat directors and writers a little
differently with a little bit more
respect and and are more the auteur
theory than here but
you know it's it's part of the problem
is if you don't do stuff that people can
make money off of it doesn't have to be
commercial
but it has to have a market
the opening pages of a screenplay
important or cliche well cliches work
for a reason
but you know if you do it well
then it works
so you mean what do you mean what's the
context of the opening how important are
they are people really tossing something
in a pile in a slush pile
based on
yeah they do but it's like if you can
grab like you have it has to play
professional it has to read professional
and it also has to have something
happening in the beginning you know and
it can't be just exposition people
sitting around talking um
yeah it is and you know i've even seen
here's another thing people don't know
is that producers will look at what the
genre is and see the page count at the
end
and it's like if you've written a script
that's like 150 pages they're like this
person doesn't know what they're doing
because no one should write a script
over 115 pages unless you're quint
tarantino or like paul thomas anderson
and if it's like a
horror movie it's 140 pages they're
going to be like what that is going on
because you know
how many pages they're all i mean if you
look at most professional scripts
they're always studio scripts or
anything they're 105 to like 112 pages
like clockwork
horror movies a little bit less you know
they're like 98 to like 104 but you know
so they see so many scripts and they
know they can you know and you've got to
keep in mind your time you're competing
for their time against professional
scripts they're getting so it's got to
be you know really awesome and it's got
to be bombastic in the beginning not not
you're blowing stuff up but you have to
grab them somehow do something somehow
you know that really shows like
you know oh wow i haven't seen that
before wow that's interesting you know
have somebody you know have adrenaline
needles jammed in their heart on the
first like you know
first line you know wakes up where am i
you do something you know and that
doesn't necessarily have to be how the
story starts but you have to figure out
a way to like make it work
and have the beginning be something
that's really really interesting
how much time do you spend on the first
page of a screenplay
not much
maybe like 10 minutes
maybe five it just depends on the on the
flow but a lot of times when i first
start something i'll just be like this
and i kind of know because i've thought
about the beats of what i want to happen
and then i'll go back and rework it
you know so it's like i'm more concerned
not necessarily with all the dialogue
you know line for line but more what the
scene is saying like what's the
beginning middle and end of the scene
and what's trying to get across and then
go back and finesse all that stuff and
two now i've
i do a new system now where i don't
write any description while i'm writing
i'll just say describe office
you know and then go back and do that at
the end because it doesn't have anything
to do really with
the story
it slows you down yeah
yeah
would paneling you know file yeah
exactly and go back and do all that one
time at the end
interesting so you put in like a little
space holder yeah explain city explain
the car you know describe here
now if it's really important the story
maybe i'll put it in but if it's just
you know like if the spy movie it's like
and you got to describe paris you know
as the sunrise comes up i'll do that
later just put established pairs they
just keep going because that's not you
know that's easy to do
how do you write a screenplay in two
weeks
i think a bigger question how do you
write screenplay in two days because
i've done that um
it's actually like the time
writing is differs but it's like how
much have you thought about it you know
because
there's times i think i said earlier
i'll think about something for two three
weeks before i even touch the keyboard
about the story and run a lot of in my
head
and if i get a big chunk of it it's like
i could just write 20 30 pages in a day
but i've thought about it it's not just
i'm like looking at the blank page i'm
not one of those people stares at the
computer i'll go for walks
you know i'll get coffee do whatever you
know ride a bike that's where i get all
my ideas
and for some reason driving um
but it's like you almost get in this
zone of like thinking about things and
sometimes when i'm stuck i'll go for a
walk i can come back and write like five
or six scenes because i just saw it on
my head
so
yeah that's that's the process i mean
there's one screenplay i wrote two two
days because i forgot when i was
supposed to deliver it and this is when
i was first writing
and then it became
you know it was supposed to be a half
million dollar little action movie that
became a 10 million dollar film you know
and i wrote in two days
so but there were a lot of parameters
set on that job it had to be one
location
don't want to change wardrobe the actor
can't talk too much because he's an mma
fighter like there are all these things
and i just was like you know what i kept
putting it off because i really didn't
want to do it i got paid and i was i
wrote in a weekend
and then it became a 10 million dollar
film they didn't really use the script
it kept changing and changing but it you
know so it you never know
strange things happen in this business
what's an example of lingering too long
on a film project um
that's a good question it's you mean if
you write a script and you keep trying
to get it made and getting it made and
it's not working
um
yeah i don't know it depends on who
you're talking to if you don't have any
contacts and you're slowly building up
you know who you know and getting people
to read it you know it could take a
process of years but if you had a
project that you gave to your agent your
manager and you had some producers read
and everybody was kind of like not
really
jiving with it i would say you know
put it away and write something else so
it kind of depends on where you're at
you know it's like if if you've got a
great script but you don't have access
to get the proper people to read it for
a couple years it's going to take a
couple years
so
your instinct should tell you everything
though people are really responding the
right people if you can get some right
people to really read it you know if you
do one of those
you know coverage things or something
and they give you 50 pages of coverage
maybe you're in trouble you know but
so so that's i don't really know the
answer to that but i think you just have
to use your instinct on what's working
what's not
sometimes you write a script and you
know it's not good enough how do you
know
again just instinct it's like you know
i've worked on things where it's like
it feels great
but it doesn't feel amazing like it's it
feels like it's almost there or maybe
the first 60 pages are seem really
amazing but the the third act doesn't
work
so you just have to know i wrote a high
script recently i was working on you
know i got inspired and quickly wrote
this high school i think the first 60
pages are great but the the third act is
horrible which usually not something
that happens it's not horrible but it
doesn't keep up with the rest of the
film and
i'm not getting any inspiration to
to come up with the third act so i just
put it away for now you know maybe i'll
revisit it in six months or three months
or two years from now but you just kind
of have to know when things are working
and when they're not you know are you
banging your head against the wall
that's not good
you know if there's something that you
feel is like
you can't crack the nut all the way
through or figure it out you should
maybe think about something or put it
down for a while sometimes you can put
something down and come back to it you
know there's a lot of people i know a
lot of directors i know who worked on
things for years they put things away
and they come back to them and they'll
be like hey
wow this is pretty cool but they have a
fresh perspective on it all
was there a project
that taught you how important your
instinct was
maybe you didn't pay attention to it
before when it came to writing
yeah i think it happened i think the the
movie rage that we did the screenplay
was called tokarev originally um i love
this movie this british film called the
long good friday which uh
um has bob hoskins in it it's from the
early 80s and i was like i want to do
something like that and i kept thinking
and then i mentioned to a few people and
they didn't know the movie or they just
were like yeah whatever and i was like
no this could make a really cool
thing you know
tony it was that kind of movie the story
is completely different but it kind of
had the same tone
and
that was when we were writing a lot of
horror things just doing horror shaun
and i were just doing horror that's all
i was working on and i was like no this
thriller is a cool thriller and it's got
a lot of things
that are going for it and
i wrote like half the script in like one
day i just kept thinking about then i
sent over sean he did some work on and
we finished it and
it got amazing response and it was
one of those times where i was like
i think
i need to move from horror into thriller
stuff and this is like a really cool
idea and it worked you know and
everybody loved the script and it got
made and
did really well for us so because of
that you realized okay i can trust
myself
yeah yeah
same thing happened with writing a pilot
too for that we sold the abc it's like
we never worked in tv and then one day i
was like we should write a pilot
we decided to write a pilot and had to
find copies of pilots to even know the
structure
and i think we called our manager it's
like hey can you send us some pilots and
wrote a pilot without ever knowing
anything about pilots and there was a
bidding war between abc and nbc for when
we sold it didn't get made but
it was like another one of those times
where it's like
i don't know never worked on tv but it
feels like maybe we should do some tv so
yeah just follow a lot of instinct stuff
works don't know why
do you worry about your movie ideas
being stolen
no because if you only have one idea and
it's stolen and you can't come up with
anything else then
you're in the wrong business it happens
i mean it's it happens you it's just
part of the business also too i i
honestly believe there's like once you
think something and a producer said this
to me once it kind of goes into the
ether and other people can pull it out
of the air
and look there's a lot of people who
independently have the same ideas
i've seen it happen time and time again
and um
you can't worry about it it's
i mean it and there's no way to prove it
it's a different situation if you sent
someone a script and you have proof that
they read it and then they come up with
something completely different but if
there's some kid in you know
new york writes something and somebody
somewhere else who doesn't know each
other have almost very similar ideas
that's just happenstance
so you know you can't really worry about
that kind of stuff and if you only have
one idea and you're worried about
somebody stealing it then
you know good luck because you have to
have a million ideas to do this for a
living
did you worry about it more before you
talked to this manager who said that
they're in the ether they're in the
zeitgeist and
no they can be pulled out and no
not really
it's just because it could happen you
know it's it's like
but you know
just sometimes people come up with
almost identical ideas just happens but
you can't worry about that stuff
you have to just keep going yeah yeah
what about having a script stolen
i mean there's ways to
here's the thing i i have to like give
people lectures about all the time is
copyright your scripts don't register
them with the wga i mean you can but
there's different levels of protection
if you copyright a script and then you
have legal recourse you have to like sue
somebody or something you can actually
sue for legal fees if it's just
registered or something else you can't
there so you have to always copyright
your script so if you're worried about
that spend 55 whatever it is copyright
it
that's the best protection in the world
what would you do if somebody blatantly
stole one of your screenplays
um
well if someone blatantly stole it i
would
have some kind of paper trail that would
be the reason i'd use it they blatantly
stole it like i sent it to them or
something like that but you also have
you know a system of like
you know you have a lawyer you have
an agent you have a manager who sends it
out at you know a professional level and
no one steals anybody's ideas it's kind
of protected by them doing that work but
if you were uh you know a screenwriter
in the midwest and you sent it out
you just have to keep track of who's you
know
here's the problem you can't copyright
an idea either
so you can't you can copyright you know
the entire script but if somebody takes
a similar idea and writes a different
version of it there's not much you can
do that's why there's a lot of movies
that are very similar movies
so i wouldn't worry too much about it
and just just get really good at
screenwriting and you'll be fine
can you take us through the process of
how you pitched abc yes this is a
question i get asked a lot is
with um
tv projects are very different than film
tv
you don't have to have a pilot you let
me rephrase that you have to have a
pilot if you have to write out a pilot
if you don't have a history of writing
like if you don't have a track record
and haven't sold anything
now if you have you don't have to write
a pilot you have to write a pitch but
for most people who are coming up you
have to actually write the pilot for the
show now what you do is you write a
pilot for a tv show it's whether it's 30
pages 60 pages you write that pilot
episode and then you write a tv pitch
now the pitch
is only
is would be a verbal pitch you would
pitch which is only 10 minutes long and
all you cover is what the show's about
the characters the beats and the pilot
and where it's going the next few
seasons you don't need to write like a
50 page
bible that's not what they want to hear
tv pitches you're only supposed to pitch
from 8 to 10 minutes in a room and
that's it
now
they they will ask you a bunch of
questions afterwards if they're
interested
but you don't need to like do work i see
these people who write these 50 page
bibles and do all this work and you
don't have to do it that's not how you
get a tv show sold tv show all you need
is a
like i said the proper pitch and which
is a format which is just simply about
the show the characters a few beats in
the pilot where season one's going and a
few beats for season two that's all they
care about they care about the
characters more than anything and what
the show's about because you got to live
with those characters for years and you
have to have a pilot now more likely if
you sell it they're going to make you
rewrite the whole pilot anyway but you
have to show to the execs that are
buying things that you can perform and
write it that's why if you don't have a
track record you have to have a pitch
and a pilot but if you do have a track
record you don't necessarily have to
write a pilot and they don't even want
you to nowadays because they want to be
involved in in every step of writing the
pilot
so not only having great characters but
characters that can actually grow and go
somewhere how are you factoring any of
that into this eight-minute pitch or no
that's for them to decide
can we go anywhere with this character
no that that goes in your pitch and when
you cover season one and you talk about
where the the show's going like let's
say it's ten episodes you don't go
episode by episode you just say kind of
you know start of season one middle
season one end of season one but a lot
of what you're talking about is where
the relationships go like if character a
becomes involved with character b and
then character c is upset about that so
it's not so much plotty as opposed to
where the characters fall into the
storyline and how they change and adjust
because
he said tv you're living it's like being
married you know with these characters
if you have a show and you're going to
do 50 episodes people have to have a
reason to keep coming back to these
characters so they have to grow and
change and things have to happen to them
is there a certain time of year when you
can pitch networks
yes um
[Music]
not
let me rephrase that not so much anymore
it used to be you would pitch like
in i think it was july through september
because then they would be starting to
set up for the next season but now with
streamers and all that it's kind of
year-round they'll take pictures any
time it's only really in regards to
abc's cbs
nbc like the big networks they still
stay more on a schedule because they
still like to have a lot of shows come
out you know in september
october that kind of time frame that
they've been doing you know for decades
but nowadays no not so much now they'll
listen to pitches almost any time of the
year so it's kind of the streamers have
changed all that there's no real season
to anything
what are the steps to pitching a tv
hoof show
lot well first of all you've got to get
a great pitch together and usually you
have a producer you're working with
who's taking you into the you know the
networks or a company like the one we
when we sold our show to abc we had
first sold set it up at lionsgate so we
went in to abc nbc we went to every
network in one week they make you do it
almost like consecutively so that if one
person is interested someone else will
also come aboard you know and they'll
get them playing against each other so
you almost go like you'll get a pitch
grid that's like 24 pitches in like four
days
and you just go place to place to place
do the same thing but you bring your
producers in and the real work is
working with your producers on the pitch
you know because when we were very lucky
that the lionsgate execs had sold a lot
of shows and they were really awesome
people and they made us do it with them
work it over and work it out
and had us
they literally time us they'd be like
okay you only got eight minutes go
and you do the pitch they give you notes
you rework it you rewrite it
and you do it again and again and
they're the final like kind of decision
makers about what the pitch is going to
be like because they're the sellers
really even though you wrote the show
so you know that there's going to be
back to back this is pitch week and so i
you plan out your whole sort of life
schedule around that and wardrobe and
you know
coming in with this producer like how
stressful is that to know that you're
going to be
on even though writers sort of
don't want that yeah i'm very stressful
um you just have to do it
you just do it i mean a pitch gets
easier and easier the more you do it
you know so the first one or two might
be a little clunky but you just the
whole process is to really give them
what the show's about tv moves super
fast faster than phil you get what the
show's about and then you try to get it
after eight minutes into conversation
get a conversational where hopefully
they ask you a bunch of questions and
you talk more about the show but you
only talk at them for like a good eight
minutes
can you talk about the bible versus the
pitch versus writing a pilot yes well
the the pilot's a pilot whether it's a
30 page pilot 60 page pilot which you
have the pitch is like maybe a six or
seven page document maybe less that you
know you you verbally will read to them
in the room you usually don't leave it
behind you go in because they like i
mean with covid it's a little bit
different but they've been doing it on
zoom you leave the pitch you do the
pitch but you don't leave it behind
now a bible doesn't get
created until the show has been ordered
so a lot of people get mixed up on these
the bible is like the bible that
explains the characters the show so it's
it adds con you know creates um
continuity through the writer's room and
from episode to episode so a lot of
people will be interested in creating a
bible it's like it's an unnecessary step
you don't do that until later in the
process there's only two things you need
a pilot and a pitch
if you're a new kind of screenwriter
wanting to sell a tv show
so don't worry about how do you make the
pitch bible or excuse me don't worry
about how you make the bible because you
know we get we see that
once that once it's greenlit or once
it's getting close to to
being told yes then yeah you're putting
the cart before the horse okay it
doesn't need to be done and most times
too like if they like your pilot more
than likely it doesn't i mean sometimes
they'll be like this is great let's
shoot this but more than likely they're
going to want you to rewrite the entire
pilot with their input like there's
something they really dig they like it
but they're going to want to do it more
their way
and if it's a big network or you know
tnt or
amc
they know what they want you know so
they're gonna be like this is great but
let's do it this way
how much time did you spend writing on
the pitch
um it took several
passes at it so maybe it was like about
a month where you maybe i mean not a
month full time but you know you kind of
work on it send it over work on it send
it over practice it a couple times do it
you know and
and just get everybody's input you know
so we were very lucky like i said we had
lines get involved which there were
several execs so they would all hear it
and then they put in their two cents or
say justice change that that's great
um so yeah it's like a sales process
it's it's a creative process but it's
also like
selling something so that's a little bit
different of a mindset so you know you
have those eight minutes but then what
about the talking points that are more
conversational afterwards are you
preparing if they ask me this then i'm
gonna say that
yes we would always write down some
talking points just to have them as
additional things but usually they would
ask enough questions
that um it would get conversational and
you would you would encourage it you
know and try to talk about it and also
we brought in a few visual presentation
things too like boards that had kind of
the world and some character stuff so we
know we realize really quickly that if
you bring those in
it's kind of uncomfortable for if you're
pitching to five or six execs for them
to just stare at you the whole time for
them so if you have like tone boards and
things they can look away and i think it
makes it more you know relaxing for them
too because it's a very unnatural thing
for you just to be talking at somebody
and then just looking at you the whole
time so and the tone boards made it more
conversational but yeah we actually
after one or two of those started
writing out talking points that kept
coming up and things to add on top of
the pitch that were like more
conversational
so by the by the 23rd pitch
you had it down so well that
you were like why didn't i do it this
way to start out but yeah a little bit
you get really good at by the time
you're done so yeah
what other materials are needed to pitch
a network show
um
it depends it's
i've heard some
tv execs say like thank god you didn't
bring in a visual presentation you know
with the the
the you know the monitors and all the
stuff and because they see so many of
those so i don't think
it's really
necessary because these are smart
executives if you're pitching to a tv
exec at netflix or somewhere they know
how tv works and they know if it's a
show so i
you know it helps depends if you're
world building then maybe it might help
a little bit more but if it's like a
drama in you know the midwest
they get it they you don't have to show
them this looks what
uncle charlie looks like and this is you
know they know so so you don't really
need to bring much but you have to have
just a really solid quick pitch and you
know and and back it up and be able to
answer any questions they have too and
the weird thing is sometimes they don't
ask anything and they're the ones who
buy it so you never know sometimes
they'll ask a million questions you're
like oh that went great and then they
pass
so
that's pretty much what you got to do is
just just follow your your you know what
you think is best for that certain type
of show you know obviously if it was
something based on ip you would bring in
vip you know if it was a comic book
you'd bring in big blow-ups so the comic
book can go these are our characters but
if it's a small intimate thing you would
i don't think you need to do that
how many times have you pitched a tv
show pitched several um
that one sold a couple sometimes they
don't sell and for various reasons like
um
maybe somebody else just announced a
show that was very similar you know so
that happens
as well um
and pitched a couple where we got hired
to write pilots but they never got on
air so probably like five or six times
and two or three of them sold but it's
becoming more and more um
really competitive as of late because
now everyone's in tv you know a couple
years ago it was a little bit easier now
they want you to bring a whole package
you know to pitch a tv show right now
you kind of need to bring in a director
of the pilot the show runner you know
the the the producers who are they want
big producers to kind of get it going so
it's become much more competitive than
was a couple years ago
can you talk about how you actually got
in the room did you know someone that
brought you in well i was fortunate
enough that that i was
with paradigm agency at the time and um
had an amazing tv agent rich rogers and
he did it all he just said look i love
this pilot you guys are going to sell it
and uh let's go to production companies
first
so we did that we went to six or seven
production companies lionsgate
paid paid us and bought the project and
then became our producers and then we
went out and then lionsgate sets you up
with the
the networks and so it's a two-step
process
first your agent will get you with
producers if the producers latch on then
the producers take it over from there
and then they will set everything up for
you and take it out and they make all
the meetings and they have a track
record usually with these networks and
have other shows on there with them so
so it's two step process
so they want rept writers you're not
just meeting somebody at a coffee shop
and hey you know what i want to bring
you in why don't you yeah i mean i think
tv
is a little bit yeah harder than
features to get in with with
features you can get in i think a little
bit easier meet producers and talk tv is
a little bit tougher without an agency
but
you know it depends on what you're
trying to do if you're a screenwriter
and you want to work in tv are you
trying to sell a show or are you trying
to become a you know staff writer staff
writer is a lot easier selling a show is
a big you've got to put all these pieces
together and and have all this stuff
thought out now if you write a good spec
pilot
and you want to get on a tv show you can
maybe find an agent to send it out to
people and you know or meet people or
work in a writer's room like i said
before and you know being a writer's
assistant and get on a staff that's a
little bit that's a lot easier than
selling a show selling your shows
you're the creator and that's your show
so people now are bringing in teams you
said so show runners
they want to package everything and even
sometimes actors you know so
and they would all come in not barring
coven not being around but they would
all come in
previously as a group yeah
yeah which that's a hard package to turn
down when you know jj abrams walks in
with his whole crew and you know so but
that's the that's the advantage to
hooking up your pilot or your project
with a big production company you know
they can do that they can go get you
know show runners they can go get those
people so
tv's become very
very competitive as of late you know and
it wasn't always seems like but you know
it's it's become tv's become a beast you
know last few years so it's it's really
great people making tv so that's another
question you have to ask yourself is
like look who i'm competing against you
know so it might be better for
somebody starting out to really write a
spec pilot and try to get in a writer's
room and try that should be your goal is
like how do i get on a staff
and write you know for two three years
make a living at it and then make those
connections get the agent
then you can write your own you know
project and get it out there
the bigger a production budget the more
problems no i've seen that i
have found that you have the same
problems on a million dollar movie that
you do on a 10 million dollar movie and
i know people who have produced 100
million dollar movies that said they're
the same problems on a million dollar
movie on 100 million movie it's always
time money actors producers screenplay
it's the exact same problem just more's
at stake
is the stress level higher because more
is at stake
i would think so i've never produced 100
million movie but i get stressed out
producing just a million dollar movie so
i i would think so
but across the board you've heard from
others that it's the same does it matter
same problems that you know just the pay
is a lot less if you're doing a million
dollar film versus 100 million dollar
film so yeah i've heard people say the
exact same problems
did you pitch in the mirror did you no
okay no